we all know the new Disney movie zombies
is constantly compared to descendants
and even some actors seem to think so
but are there any actual similarities
between the two Disney series today
we're breaking it down wanna stay in the
loop about all the Disney Channel
original movies and more subscribe to
the things and give us a thumbs up now
check out descendants vs. zombies 5
differences and 5 similarities the story
let's start with the story which is
probably the most intriguing part of the
two movies it's been pointed out that
zombies can be easily compared to
descendants and even High School Musical
the story follows a simple archetype two
characters who are on the completely
opposite sides end up falling in love
with each other but of course first they
have to fight an inner battle whether or
not that love is okay and if it's
actually stronger than whatever their
society or their parents tell them
sounds familiar
this story might actually be much
clearer in zombies although you can
definitely see the same story in
descendants with Malin been falling in
love that was a similarity between the
two but there are also a few differences
when it comes to the actual story
descendants come with a slightly deeper
and more complicated storyline that
involves plenty of other characters but
you can clearly see who the story is
about in zombies as the movie mainly
revolves around two main protagonists
dead in Addison and while said in
Addison's parents weren't villains they
do definitely disapprove of their
children's stepping out of line this is
definitely a lesson in storytelling
because as long as you have the main
storyline down you can pretty much dress
your characters in anything they can
become the children on through these
villains or in zombies casewell zombies
the storyline remains completely the
same and it's up to the production team
to decide what to do next this is where
descendants and zombies become different
descendants comes with four main
characters while zombie has only two the
studying of the movie is also completely
different even though we definitely see
the descendants in a high school we'll
talk more about that in just a little
bit but the main difference that sets
the two stories apart is that the
dissidents are an extension of much
beloved stories of popular Disney
villains it brings together several
stories of some of our favorite villains
who even make an impure
to have their own storyline this also
helps when it comes to drawing enlarge
their graphics who were once in love
with the original Disney movies because
let's be honest a lot of us actually
wrote fan fictions about this exact
situation meanwhile zombies characters
are very fresh they're not based on any
other Disney character and their story
only belongs to them this gives them a
completely unique point of view and
almost makes it seem like the plot
doesn't have any similarities to any
other movies well at least on the first
sites after all it's characters to make
most of these stories are completely
unique right so let's talk about them in
more detail the characters when it comes
to the characters the movies are very
different in descendants were introduced
to mal Evie Carlos and Jay who go on
various adventures and battle and sing
it out along the way these are the main
protagonists of the movies even though
the franchise also comes with popular
side characters like Harry hook or uma
which is definitely one of the main
differences between zombies and
descendants and in descendants each
character has its own unique struggle
outside the big storyline for example
now is focusing on being in tune with
herself and letting go of her fears
after she realizes being evil really
isn't all that amazing and it's much
better to be on the right side on the
other hand Evie's lessons is all about
finding the meaning of true love
Carlos is all about beating his fear of
dogs and Jay realizes the importance of
teamwork and trusting people before
protagonists have unique personalities
and their challenge is greatly
contribute to the movies after all these
movies definitely wouldn't be the same
without these four characters so let's
look at the characters and zombies
because although they are very different
there's a similarity between the two
movies for the first time ever we're
introduced to the two main characters
known as dead and Addison
unlike the syndromes both the Dead and
Addison have a very similar struggle
which is going against what society has
taught them and accepting they're in
love other characters in the movie
include [ __ ] Eliza free and so on
banana gun have deep storylines
well almost none of them just like
Carrie and descendants
it seems that Bucky easily steals the
show in zombies Bucky's the coach of the
popular cheer squad and he's the main
and Thainess of the movie although the
focus is definitely not on him as much
as it should be
he really disapproves of his sister
Addison being anywhere near Zed the
zombie which as you can guess can turn
out to be quite challenging for his
sister Bucky is definitely similar to
Harry hook as they're both totally
arrogant but also maintain an admirable
level of sarcasm while harry hook
definitely doesn't know how to cheer he
does know how to smirk at the right time
and we feel like Bucky definitely has
those qualities too one of the biggest
differences between the characters is
definitely the ability to continue the
story with descendants but can the
zombies do that or their story finished
enough about characters are there any
differences and similarities between the
actors and their personal stories let's
find out the actors the cast of both
shows is definitely interesting and you
probably know the names of the
descendants actors more than you know
the zombies so we'll talk about the
zombies first speaking of did you know
that there's a cheerleader in zombies
whose name is Meghan Trainor
unfortunately she has nothing to do with
Meghan Trainor the singer anyways back
on the subject zombies come with some
pretty interesting actors Zaid is played
by Milo Manheim who made his first TV
debut with his role in the movie
however he performed in 15 after school
musicals when he was younger
MacDonald II who plays Addison is
probably best known for her role as
Taylor Otto an American housewife
although the series wasn't nearly as
successful to make her a household name
Kylie Russell who plays Eliza also had
some acting roles under her belt before
zombies did you know she even appeared
in a Girl Meets World episode if you
know that apart from the two we'll
mention it in just a bit
the cast of descendants has a very
similar story to the actors of zombies
and the majority of them are actually
completely brand new to acting or they
only ever had a small movie role but
what about their differences let's go
more into detail about that as we
discuss the actors of descendants so
while most of the descendants actors
were actually quite new to acting by the
time the first movie came out they're
pretty well established actors by the
third movie
unlike zombies the descendants franchise
catapulted of Cameron Cameron voice
booboo Stewart and Sophia Carson became
instant household names but truth be
told dove Cameron is probably one of the
most recognized actors in the series
while zombies doesn't really have an
actor that stands out because they've
been plenty
other TV shows descendants has dub
Cameron and Cameron voice dove has
previously appeared in the popular
Disney show Liv and Maddie where she
played both of the main characters
Cameron voice is probably best known for
his role of Luke Ross and Jessie which
was a major hit on the Disney Channel
now compare that the two main actors of
zombies meg Donnelly and milo Manheim
both the food didn't really have huge
roles in any shows and movies before
zombies they weren't Disney Channel
actors and they definitely didn't have
advantage of being in any other popular
Disney shows before do you think Disney
made a smart move by casting actors who
aren't really the typical Disney Channel
actors for the zombies movie the music
okay so let's talk about the music and
let's start with some similarities first
this is probably where the two series
will actually get pretty different but
the biggest similarity between the two
is that they have the exact same genre
which is pretty normal in Disney
musicals we've seen this in High School
Musical and plenty of other movies and
it's always the same both movies feature
heartfelt solos that usually express the
struggles between the main characters in
zombies case this involves music such as
stand and some day in descendants first
movie shows the exact similarities
between descendants and zombies
we have rotten to the core and my here
both of which give us an insight into
the main mission of the characters evil
like me can arguably be compared with
fired up as we get songs from both
antagonists set it off can be compared
to bam and so on and on you're in zombie
land I'm in zombie land
we're in zombie land but it looks like
we could easily be in descendants to the
similarity between the music is pretty
common as this is how most musicals tell
their story but we know that you know
there are definite differences between
the music and dom bees and the music and
descendants to the two movies might have
the same type of hot that also drives
the music but we can also argue that the
music and the quality of it is
completely different in both series who
can possibly deny that rotten to the
core is one of the best of cynllun songs
ever
on the other side someday a heartfelt
duet between two main characters seems
to be pretty popular on youtube with
almost 9 million views
in the beginning of March 2018 but even
the musical scenes are completely
different in descendants most scenes are
very dark while zombies stick to the
signature pasta green and pink colors
featured throughout the entire movie we
can't wait to see more of the deleted
scenes of the movie and who knows we
might even get songs that never even
made it on the show and two wins when it
comes to dancing we honestly can't
decide because the citizens has had some
pretty impressive dance scenes over the
years while the dancing and zombies is
definitely one of the most talked about
parts of the movie
truth be told fans will have preferences
everywhere so make sure you tell us if
you love the music in descendants or the
music in zombies in the comments below
the school's one of the most talked
about subjects of both movies are
definitely the schools we all know or
add-on crap is quickly gaining the
Hogwarts reputation but people seem to
also love the idea of Seabrook high
school the biggest similarity between
the two schools is that they both seem
to accept villains in auradon crap it's
of course the descendents and in
Seabrook high it's the zombies both of
the schools are totally fine with
getting on board what feels like some of
the most problematic characters ever and
both of the schools also make sure that
even problematic characters can learn if
you look at it from that perspective
it's pretty awesome isn't it who would
love to attend a school like that
although we have a feeling we've getting
a lot more trouble than the characters
of zombies and descendants do so the
buildings themselves and the purpose
behind it is the biggest similarity in
the two movies after all even
antagonists of the story have to get an
education right but if you're a huge fan
of both movies you probably know the
biggest differences between the two
schools so let's just jump right in and
explain all of them one of the main
differences between auradon crap and
Seabrook high school is the importance
of the school in the overall movie for
the characters in descendants are dime
prep is where heroes and legends go to
study it's a school everyone wants to
attend kind of like Harvard for
fictional characters but on the other
side we don't really know that much
about Seabrook High School just yet the
school although is featured in a lot of
the scenes just isn't the main focus and
we have a feeling the majority of the
fans would still want to attend our
Adhan prep more our 'adam prep also
comes with tons of symbolism and trivia
notes that
statue of king beasts can respond to
only been in shape shifts between a
human and a beast to represent that
anything is possible
while Seabrooke hai does host boat
zombies and normals it's still pretty
well normal for such a special high
school although we do hope that this
will change if zombies gets a second
movie because let's be honest we all
want to know more about these characters
are a dime prep also comes with plenty
of interesting teachers and that add a
special touch to the overall story in
the first movie but that definitely
can't be said about Seabrook hi so what
do you like about each of the movies
comment below and let us know and that's
it for this video don't forget to
subscribe to the things on YouTube and
give this video a big thumbs up see you
next time
[Music]